it's a difficult phase in your life
because you know you obviously go from
being a full-time athlete at sports
person where your whole life is dictated
by training and competing and how you
sleep how you eat and then all of a
sudden you know you're into retirement
and it all just literally stops but for
me I've completely enjoyed entering
retirement tell us where the idea for
your apt Janice came from the app really
came from my you know my experiences
through my pregnancies and the journeys
that I had and yeah I just really wanted
to create something that you know a lot
of women out there can hopefully use in
a really successful way and enjoy I want
to know what it was like to discover you
were pregnant at the peak of your career
because that's a real concern for a lot
of women even though it shouldn't be you
know we didn't have a plan of when I was
going to start a family and it was all
about competitions and preparing for the
next year's championships so when I did
fall pregnant it was all kind of threw
everything into into chaos and you know
I remember having to tell my coach and
my team and everyone was really
surprised and you know that we just have
this plan and this wasn't like
essentially part of the plan you were
one of the lucky ones because you're at
the peak of your career your sponsors
your team looked after you but other
athletes are further down the rankings
probably don't have that kind of support
and obviously this was in the news
recently with the big control-c of a
Nike and suspending payments for
athletes who fell pregnant do you think
pregnant women in sport need to be
better protected
it's almost still a little bit of a gray
area because you you know you expect
athletes to perform year-on-year
and then retire and then have a family
and there's not a lot of you know things
put in place to support female athlete
I wonder how you felt having gone
through your pregnancy watching athletes
compete pregnant what was going through
your mind in terms of the physical
impact that would have on them because
could you imagine running that far along
in your pregnancy to the best of your
ability I think everybody is so
different and I think exercise is a
fantastic thing to do while you're
pregnant is it's got to be done
relative to your level of fitness and
how comfortable you are and obviously it
has to be safe for your child for me
personally I I continued exercising
through both of my pregnancies because
it gave me a mental lift it gave me
energy
it made me feel good it's what I've
always done and you know I continued
running to a point where you know I'm
not talking a fast pace I was probably
plodding along at that stage but I felt
I felt good and when I stopped it was
the time where I felt that you know my
hamstrings started to get a bit tight I
started to feel aches and pains I wasn't
enjoying running as much and it was my
body saying right this is time for you
to you know exercise or do something in
a slightly lower level in a different
way it's interesting are you watching
the Women's World Cup at the moment
because that is the flagship event that
everybody's glued to at the moment it's
nice to see you know how much coverage
it's getting and it's not just you know
showcasing the event it's the you know
the ad campaigns that are surrounding it
they're just fantastic it's just raising
the profile and giving those women you
know such amazing support which is great
to see so the perception of a women's
sport is changing for the better what
can be done to keep the momentum going
and take it to that next level do you
think about making sure we don't get
complacent that we keep you know the the
profile high of these amazing sports on
what these incredible women are doing
and the more we televise more we
showcase the more we you know offer
extra funding and financial support then
it only takes them to another platform
and you know you see live sport for the
first time it's so inspiring and if you
have the opportunity to do that as a
young child then it can make a huge
difference to to the direction that you
go in and whether you find a route into
sport
yeah women's sport is going through a
real period of growth and inclusion but
inclusions caused a bit of a stir in
athletics recently I know this is a very
uncomfortable subject to broach with
most athletes whether they're currently
competing on nor and but it's about
caster Semenya and the controversy she
recently won her appeal against that
Court of Arbitration for sport decision
that said athletes with differences of
sexual development must either take
medication in order to compete or change
to another distance now she's won that
appeal so she can carry on competing as
it stands at the moment
and I just wonder now that you're on the
outside looking in would you have been
happy to compete alongside caster
Semenya because so many people are
saying regardless of the fact that it's
a natural difference
it's an unlevel playing field for female
athletes I think it is such a complex
issue and there's you know it there's no
right and wrong here it is so confused
and live obviously and on the outside of
it now I'm not in the thick of athletics
I'm not competing I'm not amongst that
community really anymore so I'm sat on
the outside and you know I've read and
I've heard different arguments and
different sides and it's still you know
it's still very hard to understand fully
and hard and there's so many different
levels to it to understand it firstly
and then implement change where you know
caster feels protected and her human
rights are protected but also the other
athletes that are competing they feel
that they're on a level playing field so
you're inspiring moms to achieve their
goals the right way what are your goals
one more come back oh no I mean II feel
Olympics next year is there it too soon
and no I love exercising now in a
completely different way I can do it for
fun there's no pressure there's no
timeframes I don't have to jump certain
heights or anything like that and I'm
really looking forward to watching the
Olympics and yeah being on the sidelines
watching now yes anything it's been
lovely to talk to you thank you for your
time thank you